pregnant women can't live with cats this
is a huge meth
please don't get rid of your cat if you
are pregnant when cats purr it means
they're happy this is definitely a myth
cats think their owner is their mother
obviously your cat doesn't think that
you're its mother I'm doctor Carly Fox
I'm an emergency and critical care
veterinarian at the Animal Medical
Center in New York City and I'm dr.
Anton house also at the Animal Medical
Center but I'm an internal medicine and
oncology specialist today we're going to
debunk some cat man cats love milk I
mean I think this is sort of an image
that has been put forth throughout our
childhood like in storybooks and in
movies and on TV but unfortunately cats
as they get older actually are lactose
intolerant so their bodies actually
can't even digest milk as kittens they
have an enzyme called lactase which
helps them break down milk because they
are supposed to be drinking their
mother's milk but as they get older that
enzyme which is usually very present
goes away and then they're unable to
digest milk so if you feed milk to an
older cat or really any cat after
they've been weaned from their mother
they really can't digest it even though
they seem like they're really enjoying
themselves
it actually can cause gastrointestinal
upset you can go to the pet store though
and buy cat milk and the cat milk has
two things that make it special for cats
one is its lactose free just like the
lactose free milk you can buy in the
grocery store but it also has extra
torreón added to it and cats required
taurine in their diet so it's just an
extra source of that amino acid special
for cats I mean who knew cats are
nocturnal how can you be nocturnal when
you sleep 23 hours a day
the typical cat sleeps 23 hours a day
they wake up long enough to kill some
prey eat that prey and then go back to
sleep until the next time they're hungry
they're actually um crepuscular animals
they're what crepuscular that means that
they're active during dusk and dawn
which goes back to what you just said
about them hunting so that's how lions
hunt they hunt in the dusk or the dawn
where they
and you know see prey better hunt and
kill and our domestic cats actually
evolved from that so they're actually
supposed to be most active in the
morning and in the evening but not
necessarily in the middle of the night
though some cats obviously are well well
and they are most active in the morning
ask any cat owner at four o'clock in the
morning that cats walking on your head
and running over the bed trying to get
you up because I don't have to hunt for
breakfast they just have to get you up
cats hate water I can't say that every
cat hates water but I mean in my
experience of most cats definitely
dislike water as in they don't like
being bathed in water you're definitely
not going to see most cats go for a swim
I'd say most cats don't love water but
when cats are feeling unkempt perhaps
they they do like water cats think their
owner is their mother I think that they
just see you as a source of food and
comfort and cleanliness and a safe place
to live obviously your cat doesn't think
that you're its mother but they
definitely think that you're its
caretaker and they need you but you know
another person could probably fill in
that job just as easily for your cat
honestly though I don't think that cats
think that you're their mother but some
people definitely think pregnant women
can't live with cats this is a huge myth
please don't get rid of your cat if you
are pregnant cats can sometimes be
infected with a parasite called
toxoplasmosis which can be shed in your
cat's feces
if picked up by a pregnant woman this
parasite can sometimes cause birth
defects or miscarriage and that's
obviously something we would want to
avoid cleaning the litter box daily will
help with this you definitely don't want
to leave the litter box to go for more
than one day because that can increase
infection if you do need to clean the
litter box you should just wear gloves
so the best thing you can do is have
someone clean the litter box for you
which is also just great who wants to
clean their litter box it's a break for
nine months so if you're concerned about
your health or your cat's health during
your pregnancy be sure to bring up the
topic with both your veterinarian and
your obstetrician cats can see in
complete darkness
cats have great night vision they have a
ver like a mirror in the back of their
eye and you know that from taking photos
of your cat because you see that
yellow-green reflection in the camera
and that's this mirror that's in the
back of the cat's eye that helps to
reflect light around to improve their
night vision and that reflector area is
called the tepee 'dom cats really can't
see in complete darkness they still need
a little bit of light in their eye to
for it to bounce back and forth within
the eye off the tip edom so complete
darkness they cannot see and but a lot
of darkness with a little bit of light
they actually can can see human food is
bad for cats we don't recommend feeding
a human diet to cats because it doesn't
meet their nutritional needs cats are
obligate carnivores and it means they
need to eat meat so your diet is not
appropriate for cats black cats are bad
luck I mean this is obviously a huge
myth I think that black cats are bad
luck for themselves because they don't
get adopted from a shelter as readily as
a pretty grey cat or a flashy tricolor
cat so the bad luck is actually for the
cat not for you cats don't love people
or babies my mother was so worried about
this when I was having a baby because I
had these cats and she said those cats
are gonna climb in the crib and
suffocate my grandson nothing like that
happened babies are unpredictable then
they smell different than people and
they make different movements in people
and they have stinky diapers so I think
this actually might partly be true it's
not that they don't like babies it's
that they're different than the people
they're used to cats always land on
their feet
well cats do have an excellent righting
reflex meaning that a lot of the times
they actually do land on their feet and
that has to do with their anatomy and
their vestibular system however
unfortunately I'm an emergency doctor I
live in New York City I see many many
many cats not land on their feet
definitely don't think that your cat
will just be fine if it unfortunately
falls out of your third story window or
even from your top of your refrigerator
and when they fall they they'll land on
their chin and they often fracture their
wrist and then if they
a belly-flop it's supposed to land on
their feet they'll also get air in their
lungs or around their lungs because
their lungs get a little tear in it and
start leaking so these injuries are
severe and life-threatening for cats so
the answer is get screens or don't open
your windows cats and dogs don't get
along I don't have any idea where this
would have come from there are plenty of
houses and households in the United
States where they're both dogs and cats
and they're perfectly fine just like
some people don't get along sometimes a
dog and cat don't get along but
sometimes you have two dogs and they
don't get along or two cats and they
don't get along so I think this is more
about the personality of your dog and
your cat than it is that they can't get
along they're not going to be the next
YouTube sensation but I guess that they
maintain a working relationship yeah
yeah good that's a good working
relationship we have to work together to
be good pets yeah let's do that
when cats purr it means they're happy
this is definitely a myth and I can tell
you I've been scratched by many a
purring cat you know I think purring is
oftentimes associated with pleasure in
cats however sometimes cats can purr for
other reasons like they're very nervous
or it's a warning actually or they're
hungry not necessarily that they're
happy one human ear equals seven cat
ears this is definitely definitely a
myth I think this is something we more
associated with dogs but if you apply it
to cats I think it's even more of a myth
well if you look at it on the reverse
end of the lifespan a cat can have
kittens when it's six months old six
month old cat would be 3.5 years in
human age and clearly no 3.5 year old
children are having babies on there oh I
hope so it doesn't work in cats no today
we debunk some cat myths there is a
little bit of truth to some of these
myths that we talked about today and I
think that's very fitting since cats are
these very particular special animals
that are a bit of like a mixed bag just
like these myths my son's first words
were meow
even look at the cat and go meow that's
kill really yeah